with shorter days ahead safety advocates
say this becomes the most dangerous time
of year for our pedestrians we know how
much of an issue it is here in the
valley of safe driving for pedestrians
and walking around this morning officers
were on the lookout for drivers speeding
through crosswalks hector mejia live
this afternoon on boulder highway near
twain with the latest hector good
afternoon
hey there john well just about 10 days
ago a man and an infant were hit and
thrown by a car while they were in this
crosswalk they suffered critical
injuries and this is part of the
enforcement out here boulder highway is
a notorious street four pedestrians
killed here along boulder highway so far
in the year
by nevada law drivers are required to
stop for pedestrians where two streets
intersect or there's a marked location
this is ccsd police officer keith habig
dressed as a ferry he's crossing boulder
highway near twain i should most
definitely catch their eye in something
this bright if someone dressed in a
bright yellow fairy costume if people
don't stop for him what chance does the
average pedestrian go jaclyn suarez
works nearby and says she sees the
safety issues with pedestrians and
drivers almost daily it seems that like
people are just daredevils and just
throwing themselves in the middle of the
street and nobody is stopping she saw a
close call this morning even while
police were out this lady was just
crossing the street in the semi
i mean it takes a while for them to stop
and he almost hit her he swerved like i
try to teach the kids a lot of times
when you're getting into a crosswalk
make eye contact with the drivers make
sure that they're going to stop don't
just keep your head down and walk across
and assume that everybody is going to
stop
so this involved multiple jurisdiction
and all they issued 71 tickets and we
should also note that since 2016 there's
been an ongoing effort to make boulder
highway safer and to redesign it
reporting live hector mejia live local
now